You know, back when I was a kid
in the 1900s,
LEGO was just a brand
of building block play sets
-that hurt like a bitch when
you stepped on 'em. -(laughter)
These days,
there's a whole LEGO...
They still hurt a lot,
by the way.
-(laughter)
-That didn't change.
But these days,
there's a whole LEGO empire!
They got LEGOLAND,
they got LEGO Star Wars.
-PHOEBE ROBISON: Mm-hmm.
-This man's horrifying,
-skin-textured LEGO cosplay.
-(laughter)
ADAM NEWMAN:
Oh, just got nails.
-HARDWICK: I know. He doesn't.
-Just one nail.
-Why was I given life and no
fingers? -(laughter, groaning)
-Chernobyl, why?
-(laughter)
-Why? -Why did I put
my hands in there? I thought
-I'd get super powers!
-(applause)
Well, we're just weeks away
from the release
of The LEGO Batman Movie,
which maybe...
-(applause and cheering)
-Listen. -ROBINSON: Yeah.
-Yeah.
-I...
may have done a couple voices
in this movie.
Maybe I did!
Maybe I'm in this movie.
-ROBINSON: Cool!
-(applause and cheering)
Okay, I am. I did.
I'm very excited about it.
Very excited about this.
So, very excited
about LEGO Batman.
Also, shortly followed
by LEGO Fences.
-I wasn't sure if you guys
were aware. Um... -(laughter)
-I...
-(applause and cheering)
Yeah.
-Oh.
-ROBINSON: I think I...
I... um... I did not get asked
to be in this one.
-Uh...
-(laughter)
Today, LEGO is expanding
in social media,
launching LEGO Life,
a new LEGO-based social network
for children 13 and under
-and probably me,
Chris Hardwick. -(laughter)
This is an Android and iOS app,
has built-in
anti-bullying measures,
chiefly that any kid cool enough
to be a bully is probably not
gonna be
-on the LEGO social network.
-(laughter)
So, you'll be fine there.
Comedians, if this trend
continues, what is the next
social network targeted
at children under 13?
-Adam.
-(as child): This many square.
-HARDWICK: Yeah. Points.
Very good. Yeah. -(laughter)
-Very good. Phoebe.
-Tindergarten.
-HARDWICK: Yeah. Points!
-(laughter, applause)
Hampton.
Uh, Puber. It's like Uber,
but for pubes.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Yes. Wait. I'm sorry.
Hang on a second.
So... you go on it
to have pubes brought to you?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Oh, okay. Great.
-I just wanted to clear it up.
-When you're low.
HARDWICK: Yeah. Yeah,
that's all I wanted to know.
-PuberEATS is disgusting.
-HARDWICK: It's...
(laughter)
HARDWICK: Well done.
Well done, Adam.